Final Fantasy type-0 is one of the best
entries in the franchise to come out in
recent years the story is set in
Orient's a world torn apart by war you
get a group of gifted teenagers class 0
through campaigns against enemy nations
while unraveling the secrets of your
existence and the mysterious powers
behind the war the story of class 0 is a
little convoluted but with 14
drastically different personalities to
contend with conversations among them
are never boring but the real heart of
the story is REM and máquinas romance
these two try to balance fighting their
own demons as well as beside class 0
struggling to protect each other and do
what they think is right the main
narrative however gets convoluted very
quickly concepts and ideas are
introduced briefly never fully explained
and then thrown into high importance
later in the game things get a little
weird a little too quickly without much
cushioning but the way the game handles
relationships through the lens of war is
heartwarming type zeroes combat however
is marvelous you're fourteen playable
characters have four moves each
available to them all of which can be
customized you have three characters on
the battlefield at any time but can only
directly control one the other two are
guided by some very effective smart AI
you're never left swinging on your own
your skirmishes feel like a cohesive
team rather than a single hero
accompanied by unnecessary deadweight
you can also swap between your three
characters on the fly switching up who
you control directly typically you take
on dozens of giant mechs and angry
soldiers and story missions but when
crossing the overworld random encounters
crop up these entail quickly mowing down
a group of enemies for experience points
if there are other enemies nearby they
detect your presence and the game gives
you the option to immediately fight them
or retreat this is an excellent way to
amass quick experience points and
materials but the repetition is a rarely
tedious small touches like the combat
swirl wind speed and the option to
repeatedly fight the same encounter mean
you don't have to waste time hoping from
our foes to appear in story missions you
run through a maze of connecting rooms
destroying enemies mercifully type-0
adds a handful of checkpoints to each
level allowing you to save frequently
some battles add other combat elements
like airstrike support and bosses that
only take damage from well-timed
critical hits missions constantly change
up their layout and goals giving rise to
a vast number of combat situations and
strategy
not only our missions varied but so are
the combat systems of each class zero
member swords size flying cards a magic
flute it's great testing them all out
and customizing their attack retinues
all Toltecs zero does combat and
customization better than many of its
fellow current role-playing games
type zero looks good but it's an uneven
visual experience due to the
inconsistency of its high-definition
paint job the main characters look great
but characters who are not part of class
zero or are not important to the
storyline don't benefit from the same
care and attention Final Fantasy type-0
is about the fluid and frantic action
the overarching story is a little messy
but it vividly addresses the ugly side
of war the blood the gore and the
sadness that lingers even after you
forget what you've been fighting for
it's a worthwhile investment for the
battle system alone and the world of
Orient's feels truly alive